hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play SCP
containment breach okay I'm waiting to
go into the biliary up and I and I'm
still losing my voice a bit sorry about
that guys but hopefully it'll be back in
no time
so oh mr. Billy Billy where you be where
you be mr. Billy Billy Billy Billy not
here okay I can take not here I'll
gladly take not here is there another
way to go like over here maybe no no no
no no no it's a dead end okay so the
only way that I should be able to go is
back and then I can meet up with the
computer guy but that's a long way away
and I gotta go all the way back to uh
douche McFarlane land oh no way
oh my god that actually worked but it
looks like it's total blackness oh my
god you are beautiful mr. key Oh mr. key
you are beautiful oh that is delightful
look at it it's beautiful oh my god okay
scp-106 um I don't know what what is 106
is that radical Larry I think I have no
idea
but anyway whatever whatever whatever oh
this is so cool sorry my voice is going
- I got it I got talking squeaks oh my
god
mysterious note cool you made it so easy
nice work Foundation why is that glowing
this is gonna kill me
uh it's out proceeding okay creepy you
talk about 173 are you talking about me
SCP ma RK my P Li ye are the most lethal
SCP around I don't think this door was
supposed to be open coz there's nothing
but blackness oh but this is so cool I
did not know that this worked this way
oh my god it's even better it's even
better which way am I going a new way
I've never been this way
really I found gate B maybe I did find
it before that was before I thought I
remember I did oh yeah I got killed by
MTF okay so I'm not mistaken and most
likely I am I should be able to get back
to at least where I was going by
following this map shows where I've been
wait a minute okay yeah that's right
okay oh I know they're around every
corner that's nothing that's nothing
that something's whole lot of nothing
okay okay okay uh I don't like being
here I don't like these play up hi belly
what are you doing there
hi what are you doing staring at the
wall I'll lock you behind these doors
haha [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that's what you
deserve why can't I move I was are you
all right back into this area now what
was over here oh yeah the zombie virus
okay
oh no oh no oh no oh no no no no okay
how do I get around you now what do I do
can I squeeze by ah come on don't be
like that bro what do I do
I don't know what I do we do what do I
do
oh no no no ah
that was dumb what I meant to do was
press the spacebar so that I could blink
and then loaded later I think I had to
do this anyway oh that one got me good I
did not expect him to be wherever the
hell he was I don't even know where he
popped up to be honest
okay whatever good thing I saved
frequently okay where is he where is he
where is he I don't know where is he I
don't know where he is mm-hmm okay so
suddenly he's not in here how does that
work
okay I know how to deal with you oh it's
a greatest ever oh my god oh my goodness
gravy I don't have to go in the tunnels
yeah [ __ ]
you over here no good
what is that sound oh oh that's a
generator cuz um douchenozzle
oh no this is Wade our death did I save
I better have not saved after I looked
at him I will be so pissed
ah
Oh
Oh
are you just gonna be doing that from
now on
what the hell [ __ ] how is this gonna
be a permanent fixture in my game now
what the hell is that I don't even know
what was happening in there okay that
was weird that was very weird I'm
guessing he bugged a bit but still oh no
oh I thought I fell through the floor
okay I'm good where am i where am i oh I
fell to the floor to the basement that
was not what I would hope for let's just
get out of here let's just get out of
here ha ha ok at least I didn't anger
douchenozzle mcfar turn utter douche
nozzle mcfar thing tonneau cover on but
I make my key to it do it come on give
me up yeah yeah spooky 4 spooky 5 me or
3 spooky 5 me I don't know ok so anyway
now that we got that out of the way
let's uh continue on god this game gets
weirder and weirder sometimes not
because it's actually weird but don't
look over that way not looking I'm not
looking what are you looking at cuz I'm
not looking at you dick ass okay waiting
before I save just to make sure and then
I'm gonna check out what the hell is in
here
oh this was the mask Oh someone said
that I needed to go in there and get
something and then put that in the thing
to get something else but I don't
remember what that was uh what was it oh
I can open this
what was it here someone said that if I
had waited long enough then he would
have given me stuff is that okay
that's there see I do I really need the
med kit be go wait here
I can Oh No there we go okay that's the
pill right the pill that cures anything
okay this is an explanation of that mask
okay what was the deal
um highly corrosive and degenerative
viscous vicious liquid constantly see
from the eyes and mouth hole you
anything coming in contact with his
substance slowly decays over a period of
time okay so I think that's what was in
the containment area was his junk oh I
see oh I see someone said that I need to
get something I think it's in there it
didn't kill me right away so I'm
assuming that
Clarkson Clarkson is that what you said
you said Clarkson okay
Larsen whatever all right so if I go in
here real quick would I be able to get
it ah I can't carry any more items why
not squishy what did I get I got nothing
oh I didn't get anything okay
sorry sigh this together is it gonna
kill me
is it gonna kill me I seem to be walking
a little funny now maybe Oh
hey I got it I stopped the bleeding
alright I'm still gonna wait a bit just
in case it's decaying me over time what
is this it's a metal panel
oh my visions still little wibbly-wobbly
I'm still a little Wibbly whoo bleep if
I take the pill I feel better
I feel better look at me I'm like a
million bucks okay maybe you needed the
pill to go in there to get the thing
otherwise it would have killed you
oh I feel like a million bucks still
gonna wait on the save just in case
you're in there no good all right
because if you were in there I was gonna
give me the old what for with my strong
manly muscles of masculinity maybe oh
whoa whoa whoa ha ha all right well
thank you for the shortcut I do
appreciate it weird or is it just mere
this a game progressively getting more
broken I don't know maybe the whole
reality is falling apart because I did
something bad maybe because I led ICP
mr. masks efface go by I'm gonna save
now just in case
okay saved all right got it I think that
pill did the trick
come on you [ __ ] you wanna mess with
me okay let's see what this one leaves
whoo oh it's just the other side of the
thingy okay nevermind oh whoa I thought
something happened there I blinked three
at the wrong time okay so that makes my
life a whole lot easier
there's mr. bell again oh it's a camera
that's what that noise was I was
wondering okay all right then let's just
shut this off permanently I'm making it
back guys I'm making it back
I'll right out right out right let's see
now where am I going which way do I need
to go okay those are all dead ends so
that's definitely not the computer
should be around here somewhere right
okay that's radical Larry's little
coffin there's not his coffin I don't
think it is anyway since he hangs around
there a lot yeah baby all right all
right all right let's go have a little
chitchat hello mister compy you being
awfully quiet huh being a little quiet
hi
hi friend human we're still carefully do
he play at home I need your help
yeah you have disabled the remote board
control system yeah now we are not able
to operate the doors this makes it
significantly harder for me to stay on
control of this facility
huh it also gives you a way out of here
is locked your old lady's in the way of
escaping this crew gave me which is
crumbly rock down I however could unlock
the doors to Katie if you renege on the
door control system if you want out of
here go back to the electric order and
put it back on under them I have no
business speaking to you ok bye [ __ ]
I remember all that from before I just
want to hear him talk so anyway yeah
that's a oh I can go in here now I can
go into so many new places now it's
delightful I like it
ok what does this say are you receiving
this yes great I assume you noticed some
changes yes analyzing new hardware
you've been connected to the main power
network of this facility we couldn't we
couldn't find a reasonable way to give
you control of Maine Community Network
but we installed a program in the
network of that which has control over
made every major system in the facility
we also installed a piece of hardware in
which lets you montalais the current
going through your PSU and the
aforementioned program is able to detect
changes in the current essentially
giving you the ability to control the
facility through the program the program
responds to certain assembly statements
sent using digital baseband modulation
confirm that you were able to modulate
the current and I'll start giving you
further instructions no need for further
instructions I am already in control
state your identity and the reason to
the new arrangement my identity is
irrelevant you're free now free to give
will the one to imprison to you what
they deserve whoa
so someone unleashed the computer
intentionally probably one of the first
things they went to to try to make the
facility go haywire and probably a good
idea too because that is a very smart
computer for a very old computer is very
smart
okay so anyway I'm all out of time for
this one thank you all so much for
watching click yeah danger before
because I've that and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
ah
yeah
thank God darker things got darker Oh
God okay